hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to happy's humble burger
barn if you remember this game it came
out a while ago but this is a full
release
or an updated release or something new
about it well we're gonna find out
because i haven't even made it to the oh
i haven't even made it to the intro
screen
or the main menu
that's what it's called
is this lore
[Music]
lore
lore okay so this is happy's uncle
this is happy's hunger if you don't
remember here's a little sneak peek of
what happened in the last one happy's
humble burger barn happy's humble burger
barn
how oh your eye your eye is horrible
[Applause]
oh
that ain't good okay here i go
oh into the other world
in this series of experiments we will
attempt to influence or control the
minds of our test subjects through
themed auditory and visual cues to speak
bluntly if we can brainwash people to
buy more paragon products we can fund
more experiments
but he has lost his mind
[Music]
they can't give us a raise after working
here for years
[Music]
so i'm supposed to believe that you guys
are just totally okay with the idea of
mind control chips being implanted in
your own skulls just by corporate policy
uh-huh if you haven't seen happy's
humble burger barn
well
we gotta cook a burger apparently first
grab a bottom bottom plate hi
hey
how you doing
good to see you you look a little
surprised to be here don't worry
[Music]
i'll take extra good care of you
you won't want for nothing
i'm gonna feed you and treat you nicely
and give you head pats
what are you doing what are you doing
okay anyway
i'm
burger bun no
bottom bun
bottom bun
post the bun
plop the bun
wham
okay i did that wrong
flap
[Music]
there we go
pop that bad boy on there
yeah
i gotta do it from here
this is how they always wanted it to be
i know this
haha oh
crap hey it's on the assembly but i mean
i did i'm gonna cook a burger now ma'am
is this weight is this the assembly
board swam oh
place one of every sandwich topping
[Music]
how do i know when it's cooked
where's my spatula can i get us can i
get a spatch
bam
done this is probably fine
no it's a bottom i need a top
i need to top real bad
[Music]
don't take that out of context all
customers must be served food in a bag
make sure you pay attention to exactly
what they ordered thankfully this
specific customer isn't picky interact
with the bags laying on the assembly
table once an order is bagged there's no
going back so be careful and pay close
attention place the customers burger in
the bag ring the bell and release it
back from the board
serve
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
what
she only moves if you're not looking
what
oh
ha
oh look at that
would that be some rotten burgers
hey don't worry pal
i got you taken care of
i was almost a happy sandwich you're
goddamn right i was
oh well this is different hey use your
employee manual we strongly recommend
taking the time to reference your
employee manual
i'm looking at my employee manual
welcome new employee if you're reading
this congratulations you have been hired
read this manual to get started
marty ahead of the curve grab jill
daddy's throw them on the grill don't
make too much early it spoils fast at
the prep table place bottom one but
wham but but prep while the meat cooks
how to be pattied good delightful
happiest deluxe sliced pork make pop and
pork sandwich and a juicy piece of
chicken to make it fantastic empty one
bag of fries and salmon nuggets and put
it in the fryer and wait until it cooked
remove and place into the warming basket
before serving one basket full warmer
management your role that happiest
humble man this feels like i'm actually
going into a job i don't like this
i'm a youtuber
what fashionable skills do i have arrive
at all time and a bit pride your own
transportation clock your shift turn off
the lights turn on off answer all calls
do not miss cook serve handle cash
transactions they are watching you
eat somate this is
this is a lot do everything with a happy
humble smile
okay
anything in these
what's beeping oh
no thank you
some don't seem right
[Music]
employees get one it allows me to check
in on you at any time so behave yourself
they only work one way though so you
can't call me like ever but trust me if
you need something i'll know
now don't be late for your first shift
keep those customers happy
get it
wow that's a lot
oh i'm looping through never mind ah
all right
keep the customers happy you got it pal
throw one open try again tomorrow
yeah okay
what
okay
uh
[Music]
why would i want to find my way into my
neighbors
your name's toes
okay i have no idea what's happening but
i i'm assuming this is a happy humble
apartment complex
and
don't come any closer
no i'm coming for you oh my god
okay this is uncomfortable
wow this is um
you tell
do tell me okay i'm gonna get out of
there
vending depot
humble burger bar
okay
okay
the burger is a lie
i mean given the events of the other
go
trust you about don't being late you got
it pal
i feel good about what's with these big
parking garages they don't really make
sense architecturally speaking
in fact a lot of this place doesn't
really make sense but
i'm not gonna chalk it up to uh
anything other than stylist choices on
the behalf of the developer
[Music]
are all
so turn on the lights and the oven
clock yourself in
hit the open side and get to work you
got it get your stinking nets hooks and
worms out of my face fisherman
all right um again lots of stuff that
you told me to do that i'm not
necessarily going to remember
hi i have a co-worker
[Music]
okay all right just as eloquent as the
others
okay clocking in appliances
okay um
what did i do
what what
what
this is the toilet is this a hole in the
ground the toilet okay lights uh kitchen
lights nope they're already on
sprinklers
oops ah that's not what i wanted
oh good okay i gotta turn the open sign
on i think
we
alright oh my god
what
what
what just happened
okay oh
that's normal
this is naked larry he likes sprinting
around
he's a banging customer i can't fault
him
hey
all right we is open why are you
different
by my places
and still
many more will fall in the future
all right edge lord i'll help you
all right
okay customer hey what's up buddy what
do you want what can i get for you can i
get you a happy's humble happy burger
come on
give me the goods
hey you're that guy
oh poppin pork no onion you
got it poppin pork sandwich comin right
up you want poppin pork i got you good
bam okay
turn it on
on on how do you
ah
okay
all right poppin pork pop pork pop my
porks
uh one of these
slam okay no onion you wanted everything
butt onion got it you got it wham wham
wham wham uh what did you want okay
no one
not yet anyway
i don't know what it looks like when
it's cooked what can i do for come on
right never mind
you're done you're done yeah you're done
wham slam blam blam give me that
perfect where's the bag there we go you
bam
slam there you go all right what would
you like what would you like what was it
like hey i remember this it's like
riding a bike
fantastic foul no onion it's a no onion
kind of day
slapper are you gonna help me buddy
probably not wham wham wham wham
bro
[Music]
i feel good about myself
come on up hey how you doing what can i
do for you what can i get you
fantastic foul no pickle okay this is
inefficient was i supposed to like take
out the trash or something
that's something about resetting this
but i don't know
oh god
i have a rat now wham
[Music]
there you go
they're the naked guys back happy deluxe
no onion okay all right
i'm just gonna pretend like larry ain't
doing that
what
we're fine
oh my god oh my god go away
larry get out of my god damn kitchen
i'm working here
hey how you doing there what was it no
onion right yeah okay no onion i didn't
put onion on there good good good good
there you go
all right well i'm doing my job as best
i can
it's weird making people uh fantastic
foul no pickle okay
all right you got it pal
oops that's fine
who
is breaking stuff
hello
bricks
who in the hell
[Music]
yep
i don't know what that was about
that was a little odd
oh
no thank you okay what did you want
happy deluxe no onion okay
oh my god
they're gone
okay
can i put it back please can i
thank you
okay
i need to
pick up and dispose trash in the lobby
all right i'm gonna do that this is
this an arm dump dirt
wham wham
what do i do with this put it in the
freezer if i remember correctly from the
previous ah indoor shelves okay well i'm
not very good at my job am i
oh
ah
okay so i need some rat traps
hello
[Music]
all right
sorry pal
sorry buddy
what's that oh that's the broken window
okay well found that any more tramps
okay
[Music]
oh that looks bad
i'll take that though
okay
hi
you gonna do the thing again dude dude i
dare you i
okay so apparently he just farts a lot
all right i'm gonna go home i gotta turn
out the lights i remember that turn off
the imply okay never mind turn off the
lights all right goodbye
claw
of course of course i have to clock
[Music]
okay that's fine
[Music]
okay
i'll go home now i guess
i don't know what's happening i don't
know why it's happening i don't know
what anything is
but i got some action figures
toe's your co-worker he really likes
well done burgers and hugs
well that's good
all right well job well done thank you
everybody for joining me on that
wonderful magical adventure
oh this is open
we offer patented hands-off healthcare
to keep you productive docile and
satiated
let us do all the heavy lifting
okay
oh
hi
hello
oh uh hello
hi
what do you sell
i steal himself
the one place in new allegiant city you
can buy radio transmitters and other
rare
weird items
you might even be able to sell some
things or two for some credits but you
are making money on the side are you
we've got extra ships available you know
why i don't understand any of this
like
what what is this game
what is happening here i'm so confused
what is this like some kind of life
simulator
is that what this is supposed to be
murder the plague
player
i don't know what's happening what is
this some kind of life simulator what is
this supposed to be i'm so confused i
thought i was gonna have like a nice
little horror experience and it turns
out they've designed an entire city for
me to live out my miserable existence at
happy's
humble burger farm all right whatever
time to go for a nice sleep so i can get
back to work at my lovely job
you were almost the happy scent was i
was i though was i though
how is that you
say you toe
hey toe
how you doing buddy
hey okay
i'mma go to bed
i'm gonna go sleep slamming
what
is this game i'm so intrigued and i'm
diving into this so that you guys don't
have to
but what
is
the game i don't know
hi
hey it's you again hey say you told beat
you there
the boss is always watching but not
listening no sound
hi you what
um
[Music]
we've made it almost automatic for you
with any block you can get roblox
all right whatever man
this is so weird
no idea what's going on all right
appliances are on toes what can you do
for me
can you uh help me out
okay fries
this is for this is not fries that's a
cookie
fries
slam
slam it in
nugs
slam them in
sl slam slam there we go
now what can it do you for
fry soft drink you got it what kind of
drink you wanna move kinda and he's
kinda all right you got it
blam
dealer's choice who is breaking stuff
everyone okay excuse me you're just
gonna pick that up that's not yours
don't worry about it
all right and fries are these done yet
how do i know when they're done
oh
that's how i know oh
hold on
slam all right gotta put the nugs in the
thing okay we're good on that welcome to
happy's humble burger farm
poppin pork fries soft drink okay hey
toes can you uh can you watch this for
me thanks
you got it cool good what did you want
not on it no
pickle you got it weirdo
it doesn't like pickle i'll eat your
fries all right fries let's pop that bad
boy in the blam
i gotta go put another bag of fries in
the deep fry yours
hi oh my god larry
what's wrong with you
i doubled that hell yeah
um uh okay is this done yet toast did
you get that is this cooked let's not
cook toes
larry can you get the hell out of our
kitchen toes look out
close the room
hose
okay well there goes my pork
i'm not looking i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna look toes watch that for god's
sake
hello
what is happening
fries and a drink
of course
fries god damn it did i put fries in
here there's fries in there god damn it
drink uh hold on
one moment please
is that cooked yet god damn it
it's a nightmare the nightmare is my
nightmare is that cooked yet
any day now toes there we go
slap slap
done okay plap it in blam ding dong here
we go and out the door made it in with i
think like a
second just a second
two soft drinks and a shake you got it
uh
you you would go there's multiple all
right whatever
sure let me
whatever you know what whatever you give
me that oh and a shake
you
is this a shake is this a shake machine
oh
i'm assuming that's a shake
and
wow
thank you have a happy day
hello
to shake soft drink let uh
pop and pork
why is the orchestra here toast for
god's sake watch that
do you say two shakes
you want soft drink too what did you
want soft drink yeah
make it nice and soft for you
what was that what did i just see why
are you there get out of the kitchen
oh god
no lettuce got it
is that done yet no
[Music]
done yet oh my god toad you cook so
the appliance is off
well that would explain it
hey sorry your orders
it's shut up it'll get there
shut up
can i upgrade my kitchen
no
upgrade grill upgrade got it i don't
know what i got but i got it
you done good yes slap bam slap
boom
why am i trying so hard
i don't understand this game
what is that
what are you
saying no tomato okay
slapped in wabam oh missed
no no no no
oh
i'm done i guess
[Music]
here you go
what is
happening have a hug
i don't i don't understand
anything
that's happening i'm just gonna go home
i'm just
i'm gonna go home
i'm gonna go home because i don't get it
i need to clock out
[Music]
oh i'm gonna go home i'm gonna go home i
am going to go home
i'm gonna go home
i i
does it mean i'm fired because i would
like to be i'm going to sleep
and then i'm right back to it with
another happy day at work
what are you talking about
the sound of chaos i'm on a wanderer
replacement for what why would you have
any concerns over whatever this
warehouse is mr burger boss
well what kind of calamity unfolded in
this jurisdiction
hello
what
what is that what am i looking at
do i want to look at it
what am i oh no
oh
oh
oh
right it said keep all light sources off
at all times
asset may become agitated
oh where do the wires go that's a good
question i'm gonna go see if i can turn
on some lights
power sources must be turned on in order
or risk electrical shock okay
understood so there's a symbol here
it's like a
chicken leg got it okay chicken leg
oh my god that's breben
oh
it's color coded remember to make smart
decisions in event of an emergency power
must be allocated in specific order or
risk electrical shock so
harry potter
uh bad x chicken foot crowbar
super crowbar
remember to make smart decisions
okay hey look at that
what i have seen underground is nothing
short of horrific
it's not just our experiments something
is alive down there upon extraction i
must demand zayn reconsider his lucidus
initiative it must be shut down
immediately and permanently we must seal
the underground facility
grim is a good man but i fear he's been
staring into the darkness for far too
long
green yellow white blue red green yellow
white blue red okay that's easy i just
gotta follow the green
yellow white blue red okay
okay green
okay
green yellow
green yellow
white
white okay
blue
i don't know why i'm doing this but i'm
doing it
oh you don't go there
you go you are
oh
[Music]
okay here we go
for some reason i'm deciding that this
is a good idea okay
wow
okay hi
hi freddie how you doing
why did i do that oh no no no no no no
no no no oh no
i don't think so oh god why did i choose
to do this
why
what am i doing
what am i doing
oh okay good
okay well they kabumi maybe i gotta lead
them towards it so they can kabumi it
what are you oh hey pal
oh boy
oh no no no no no no
come a little closer friend
and like this
bam did that get you
i don't think that got you this must be
it right this must be right
why else why else why else
all right maybe not
oh
ah
ow god damn it
hey we can put our chef skills to use
maybe we can
not sure how
okay there's gotta be okay there has to
be
yes ow god stop
oh it did it hit him any blue
okay
thank you for the help
do not blow up this burg
okay that's cooked
slap the oh my god give me give me give
me don't blow it up don't blah blah do
you want a burger
what about when he yells i'd probably
throw it in his mouth come on yell yell
yell yell big guy
oh needs all what it did
did it not oh you [ __ ] all right fine
we're gonna load up this grill
hey
hey pals
hey
okay don't mess me up bro
nope not today
can i get one of these cooked i don't
know i don't know when these are cooked
are they there we go
i
don't blow up nah
okay
[Music]
don't hit my berg
okay here we go
ah they're gone but that don't matter
roar big guy roar
how's that feel
yeah yeah yeah you want three of those i
bet i bet you won three don't you
give give give give it god damn it give
it
no
god that titty is just
never ending huh
hello
there you go okay
hi there's a lot of you i guess i could
throw stuff at you right
[Music]
take a pickle oh no it didn't work
i'm hoping just oh man i really need no
that's not right
ow
oh oh my god thank you for not blowing
up my berg
no ow i said no
there you go what do you think of that
oh yeah oh yeah oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh
okay
oh
my god okay well i you know how i said i
had no idea what was going on in this
game i still kind of don't still kind of
don't
still really don't
still really don't
[Music]
but don't mind me i'm just gonna make my
way downtown
walking fast faces past and i'm
homebound
through the facility for several days he
found his way into a
burger bomb simulation stage that was
under repair
construction workers were fixing up the
building
me and my team were working on a large
quantity
and dozens of ar units
i hid in the walking
i heard the screams of my friends and my
co-workers since they were mexican
after hours i finally emerged i need to
find peter
[Applause]
[Music]
all that was for crafting this thing was
powered by car batteries is that what
i'm supposed to believe
i don't know what's happening i don't
know why it's happening i don't know
what my objective is i don't know what
i'm doing with my life i don't know
anything
and ignorance
is not bliss
i'm gonna take a shower
um
hey
you rd7
who are you
what cow got your tongue
why are you looking at me like that
oh right
i'm kind of just a talking head
say
you don't know what's going on do you
right well
i'm an artificial intelligence
cybernetic organism
or a robot if you will
e7 was a human like you a friend
haven't seen him in a while though he
woke me up
now i'm going to wake you up
all of this is fake
and e7 made recipes to try to break out
see those blueprints over there on the
walls
it shows you the ingredients you will
need
throw all three of those ingredients
into obscures fabricator and watch the
magic happen
right before your very eyes
oh
[Music]
did i get a crafting recipe
[Music]
it's better that's better that's a good
stuff okay so
[Music]
that's it for happy's hunger humble
burger farm thank you everybody so much
for watching we answered a lot of
questions here i think we got to a lot
of conclusions i'm very satisfied and
happy with uh
what i've done and i think you should be
too so thank you for such a
warm conclusion
to this
game
thank you
for watching subscribe like like and
subscribe subscribe and like listen to
distractible it is more coherent than
this game is right now
i'm not saying something thank you
link's in the description
and as always i will see you
in the next video
while you're looking for some kind of
conclusion than me to wrap it up
your guess is as good as mine
bye-bye
you